I hate that I have to do this next story
this first story today but I'd be doing
something wrong if I didn't and it's
about reaction to the molar report which
is not actually the molar report and
that reaction and coverage of the bar
report has been truly embarrassing and
I'm talking about reaction from media
I'm talking about reaction from many in
the public to just kind of get everybody
up to speed again we've not seen the
molar report Mitch McConnell and William
Barr are already working hard to ensure
that that full report is never actually
seen by the House of Representatives nor
by the public I'll tell you more about
that a little bit later today all we
have right now is a four page summary of
a summary by Donald Trump's partisan
Attorney General William bar and way too
many people on the right and the left
have abandoned logic and reason in their
reactions and their responses now of
course Donald Trump's reaction was
exactly what we predicted claiming total
exoneration that was written on the wall
tweeting quote no collusion no
obstruction complete and total
exoneration Keep America great we knew
that this is what he would say
but just because Trump plays his
predictable role doesn't mean everybody
else has to throw critical thinking out
the window which unfortunately has taken
place in many enclaves since this four
page summary went public number one it
was too seldom mentioned in the constant
coverage of this that we have not seen
the molar report okay the the reporting
was all molar exonerates molar clears
etc what we had was a four-page summary
of a summary as I told you yesterday we
are reacting to a partisan selective
sanitized summary of Robert Moeller
summary of the investigation anybody in
the media or on my Twitter or wherever
who is pretending that this summary
actually tells us what's in the
investigation case file is actually
damaging
the eventual ability to evaluate what it
is that Robert Muller did and didn't
find now because of people on the right
and left claiming that Donald Trump has
now been exonerated they have
participated in priming the pump for a
muted response to whatever the Muller
investigation actually found if we ever
find out the full scope of that
investigation if we ever see the actual
findings of the Moller investigation
imagine that they reveal
I don't know Muller had 80% of what he
needed to say that Donald Trump
obstructed justice but wasn't able to
establish it beyond a reasonable doubt
everyone has already reported that the
report clears the president that this is
now fake news if it says something that
is different than what was reported
after bars for page summary was
published bars letter isn't even written
in coherent legalese as I told you
yesterday in detail and there are people
in corporate media and some in
independent media and of course in
conservative media and even in so-called
left-wing media to some degree saying
the president has been cleared and
unqualified clearing exoneration of the
president do the facts matter anymore
for everyone saying Trump didn't collude
with Russia but he's still corrupt I
mean that's right and this four page
summary from his attorney general
increasingly appears to be part of that
corruption as I explained to you
yesterday if the reports can't exonerate
Trump which is what it says
if Muller cannot exonerate Trump on
obstruction that's a very damning report
and to focus the reporting merely on the
fact that Trump hasn't been caught
personally colluding with Putin which
everybody has been saying for more than
a year including me and I'll have video
of that in a second is missing the point
of the story
it is straw Manning and the number of
people who have contacted me on our
subreddit on Twitter saying David you
need to apologize because you were
proven wrong on collusion was I take a
look at this video from a year ago with
what I specifically said
about Donald Trump personally colluding
do you personally think that Donald
Trump rooted with Russia like just your
personal thought as an individual feel
like that that Trump personally was like
talking to Putin and setting things up
yeah like do you think Putin installed
some guy who doesn't know what he's
doing in our government and now he's
just here well hold on that that's too
different let's take them one at a time
if that's okay with you okay all right
question one is do I think Trump was
directly involved in coordination with
Russian agents I think the answer is
probably no I think that Trump was aware
that his campaign was talking to Russian
actors but I think the likelihood of
rump personally coordinating and
anything is probably close to zero good
beer okay second part is do I believe
that Russia installed Trump no not in a
literal sense Russia clearly had an
interest in Trump being the Republican
nominee from a pretty early moment in
the primary once he became the nominee
Russia clearly had a preference for
Trump over Hillary Clinton and they had
a number of different tools at their
disposal to help Trump so when we
pretend that people said things that
they didn't whether it's me or anybody
else we also lose so let's stop with
that because even people in our audience
are embarrassing themselves on this
issue and then lastly anyone pretending
that this is over is really missing the
boat okay the Southern District of New
York is still investigating
Trump's inaugural has now been
subpoenaed totally separate from the
Moller probe the Trump Organization is
now under lawsuits for emoluments
violations the House Ways and Means
Committee may well get Donald Trump tax
returns before we know it but the the
criticism here isn't that I think Trump
personally colluded with Putin as you
saw a year ago said I don't think that's
the case the problem is that every major
news outlet and some non major ones have
capitulated or acquiesced in a way that
is just not warranted by what we
actually have so far which is a summary
of a summary from Trump's attorney
general even if we grant barr the most
generous benefit of the
and I don't know why we would give in
his history of covering up presidential
wrongdoing this was a very cheap
propaganda attempt by William Barr to
summarize a summary in the most
favorable possible way and use it as a
data point to claim that there's been an
exoneration to every person in the media
who played along with this over the last
72 hours you're a part of the problem
and this confirms to everybody saying
that the media is liberally biased
they're biased towards sensationalism
and towards a coherent narrative the
real story here the true one is too
complex of a narrative to make a good
corporate media story so instead it's
been probed for a year now it's
exoneration wall-to-wall for the last 72
hours and their coverage of all of it
fell embarrassingly short one of today's
sponsors is privacy calm slash Pakman
this is a free service that I've
actually been using myself for a while
now and I love it
you just take a few seconds to link your
debit card or bank account to privacy
calms mobile app or browser extension
for Firefox and Chrome and what that
does is allow you to instantly create
virtual credit cards that are linked to
your bank account so that you're not
actually putting your real debit card
number on the Internet and you use these
virtual credit card numbers to buy
things online and with one click of a
button you have the ability to create
multiple virtual cards delete cards
freeze and unfreeze cards you can put a
limit on a card so a company won't be
able to charge you more than you
actually want them to and it protects
you from being hacked it protects you
from companies being hacked which we've
been talking about for a while on the
program and it's perfect for signing up
for free trial somewhere if you don't
want your real credit card number to be
exposed and on file and their app and
browser extension let you autofill the
virtual credit card number into the
credit card field when you're buying
things online there are a ton of
different advantages to shopping and
paying bills with a system like this
everything is towed
secured and encrypted and in some
situations you can earn 5% cash back on
your purchases it's all completely free
all you have to do is click the link
under this video to get started and for
a limited time everybody in our audience
who signs up gets 5 dollars towards your
first purchase when you sign up using
that link below